[Musica]
grazie ciao a tutti io ho girato
tantissime città però il mio primo
viaggio all'estero lo ha fatto a tre
anni in germania con i miei genitori
lavoravano lì e devo morto i miei
genitori perché mi hanno insegnato a
provarci a fidarmi degli altri ad andare
a vedere cosa c'è fuori poi siamo
tornati in italia dove ho studiato a un
certo punto della mia vita ho deciso che
volevo specializzarmi di nuovo
all'estero e sono ritornata all'estero
in repubblica ceca malino mi sentivo una
straniera sono stata accolta
mi sentivo semplicemente una cittadina
europea
qui a siena una città maestosa troneggia
questa sala del buon governo è una
parola molto importante e credo che
nelle smart cities il buon governo sia
fondamentale la radice antica di questa
parola zen che significa vivere come
individui in una comunità politica in
armonia con gli altri con cui noi siamo
in relazione quindi la mia teoria quale
è che le città intelligenti le città del
futuro saranno sempre più connesse ma
non soltanto attraverso i trasporti non
soltanto attraverso le tecnologie
saranno più connesse perché noi saremo
più connessi agli altri
a un certo punto della mia vita ho letto
questo libro di shell sandberg
direttrice di una grande società della
comunicazione digitale che ci dice se
quando lavoriamo i nostri ritmi non
coincidono più con il nostro lavoro è
ora di cambiare lavoro
ed è in quel momento che ho capito che
per essere in armonia con il mio lavoro
e la mia vita dovevo fare quello in cui
credevo veramente e da lì ho iniziato un
percorso per aiutare le città
soprattutto le città del sud nel
cambiamento
[Musica]
abbiamo un momento molto difficile
storico da affrontare un momento di
grande trasformazione in cui un vecchio
mondo sta finendo ucciso dai nostri
comportamenti sbagliati è un nuovo mondo
deve ancora nascere in questo mondo
abbiamo delle emergenze emergenze
sociali emergenze ambientali emergenze
etiche da risolvere ma noi possiamo
essere parte di un cambiamento
noi con le nostre azioni quotidiane i
grandi decisori del mondo possono
intraprendere un percorso di cambiamento
per rendere le città migliori cambiare
certamente non è facile perché perché
abbiamo paura
tanti tipi di paura paura
scusate paura di sbagliare paura di non
essere capiti ma papa giovanni paolo
diceva non abbiate paura
[Musica]
e come si fa a non avere paura
secondo 8 charmer docente della mt noi
dobbiamo superare tre grandi blocchi
innanzitutto un blocco spirituale del
nostro rapporto con noi stessi con la
nostra spiritualità un blocco sociale
nel nostro rapporto con gli altri è un
blocco ecologico nel nostro rapporto con
la natura
e su questa teoria anche edgar morin si
è espresso da poco in un libro sui 7
saperi per il futuro e ci dice che noi
dobbiamo recuperare un etica planetaria
dobbiamo comprendere la nostra triplice
natura cioè noi siamo allo stesso tempo
individuo è già nella parola individuo
c'è scritto indiviso quindi con
siamo anche società quindi il rapporto
con la comunità e siamo anche specie
solo se recuperiamo questo triplice
rapporto nelle nostre azioni quotidiane
riusciremo a cambiare il destino del
nostro pianeta e come si fa innanzitutto
con un nuovo atteggiamento aprendo il
cuore
aprendo la mente e aprendo la nostra
attitudine la nostra predisposizione
verso gli altri
la prima cosa che si può fare è la
fiducia creare fiducia
le città del futuro quindi saranno città
che non gestiscono i problemi di
sfiducia ma che costruiscono una nuova
fiducia fiducia verso il prossimo
ma per creare fiducia bisogna iniziare
ad ascoltare gli altri e ascoltarli
profondamente ascoltarli non soltanto
con la testa ma come dice 8 sharman
anche con il cuore ascoltarli uscendo
dalla nostra comfort zone per rientrare
nel mondo dell'altro per comprenderlo
per capire che qualche problemi a e che
cosa ci vuole dire quindi da un lato la
scorta ma dall'altro lato anche la
capacità di parlare di comunicare di
dire quello che pensiamo e soprattutto
di essere trasparenti e su questo
abbiamo fatto in questi ultimi anni
insieme a varie associazioni in italia
un grande lavoro sulla trasparenza la
trasparenza è importante la trasparenza
consolida il dialogo e il dialogo genera
fiducia trasparenza quindi significa
chiedere dei dati e dare dei dati ecco
perché il grande movimento sugli open
beta
l'altro fattore che cambierà le città
del futuro sarà il making e con questo
non intendo soltanto fare in 3d ma fare
insieme fare incessantemente fare con
coraggio costruire delle soluzioni per
premi che ancora non esistono cercare di
capire quali sono questi problemi e fare
fa le soluzioni fare e sbagliare ma
anche poi rifare fare senza paura per
esempio a me avevano detto che un libro
che avevo scritto non interessava ma io
ho continuato a crederci l'ho rifatto ci
ho riprovato ea dicembre uscirà il mio
primo libro quindi fare anche quando vi
dicono che non si può fare e su questo
ci sono anche autorevoli intellettuali
che che hanno scritto grandi cose ma
ultimamente ho seguito il consiglio
anche di jessica grande che è stata qui
in italia in visita all'ambasciata
americana jessica hynes dice
importantissimo fare insieme e
soprattutto noi donne dovremmo imparare
a collaborare di più perché viviamo una
situazione molto più difficile dal punto
di vista professionale
dal punto di vista dell'accesso ai
luoghi decisionali
quindi dovremmo imparare dice gestica
account a ad aiutarci tra di noi e
aiutarci reciprocamente e il terzo
consiglio per aprire le porte e quindi
per avere delle città più connesse e
rompere i muri aprire le porte e rompere
i muri sono due concetti collegati
rompere i muri dell'indifferenza rompere
i muri fra generazioni piccole grandi
possono collaborare rompere i muri tra
religioni rompere i muri tra generi
rompere le barriere tra città diverse
cercare di collaborare andare a vedere
cosa c'è dall'altra parte rompere i muri
significa dare a noi stessi e agli altri
una possibilità quest'estate visitato la
città di auschwitz
ecco la più grande forma di odio dello
secolo scorso
tutta l'umanita ha risposto ha risposto
con la ricostruzione ha risposto con il
ricordo ha risposto con il perdono è
l'europa
la più grande risposta dell'uomo
all'odio che non si alzino mai più muri
di questo tipo
qui samantha cristoforetti dalla sua
navicella riflette pensa e ci ricorda
che quello che stiamo pianificando oggi
determinerà il futuro dei prossimi
trent'anni e ci ricorda l'emergenza
ambientale dalle sue bellissime immagini
7 miliardi di di sogni un unico pianeta
ci ricorda quanto è bello il nostro
pianeta e quanto è importante
preservarlo
eppure tanti sono i mali da affrontare
le statistiche ci dicono che nei
prossimi anni il 60 per cento della
popolazione vivrà nelle città
probabilmente nel 2050 addirittura
saliremo all'ottanta per cento
e allora queste città si devono
impegnare si devono impegnare a
risolvere le emergenze ambientali le
emergenze globali
io immagino come saranno queste città e
sogno sogno delle città creative sono
nelle città etiche sogno dell'elite
spirituali modernizzatrici e come
saranno i leader del di queste città del
futuro sarà uno dei servan leader prima
di tutto persone in servizio
avremo bisogno di leader umili e su
questo lo smart city tour per me è stata
una grandissima lezione
dell'associazione amerigo perché città
diverse completamente diversa e più
grandi più piccole
bellissime di periferia si confrontavano
tra di loro per risolvere i problemi e
questo latitudine questo l'atteggiamento
giusto che dobbiamo avere
aspettiamo un momento in cui le
evoluzioni tecnologiche saranno
imprevedibili
il cosiddetto momento della singola reti
in cui non sappiamo più come evolveranno
le tecnologie ma questo non ci deve fare
paura
le statistiche mondiali ci dicono che
per 5 milioni di posti di lavoro che
finiranno delle vecchie professioni
oltre due milioni di posti di lavoro
nasceranno e che tipo di posti lavoro
saranno saranno nel settore delle
biotecnologie delle nanotecnologie della
stampa 3d ma che tipo di cose metteremo
dentro in questo nuovo mondo
ma sapete molto del nostro tempo si
libererà cosa faremo di questo tempo
liberato l'italia in questo momento può
essere un leader che detta la linea può
decidere di accelerare di rallentare
perché l'italia oltre a essere l'ottavo
paese del mondo per produzione di
ricchezza è anche il primo paese
il primo leader spirituale noi possiamo
decidere quindi di inserire dei valori
dei contenuti in queste nuove
professioni noi possiamo decidere di
inserire l'etica nei lavori del futuro
per me il nuovo paradigma dell'italia
nei prossimi anni sarà il dare il dare
sarà il nostro più grande desiderio cioè
dedicare del nostro tempo a chi ha
bisogno
a chi è in difficoltà informarsi vivere
nelle nei nostri quartieri conoscere i
problemi dei nostri vicini di casa e
aiutarli quanti di voi hanno genitori
anziani e quanti di questi genitori
lottano contro la solitudine la malattia
con queste mani
noi possiamo creare possiamo scrivere
possiamo costruire con queste mani però
possiamo anche fare del male possiamo
uccidere possiamo ferire con queste mani
noi possiamo decidere
che tipo di città costruire per il
nostro futuro facciamo dei nostri sogni
il nostro lavoro per futuro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]